I love cheese on my burger okay and I
get my big slice of cheese I put it into
the pan okay you see that cheese melt
very very quickly what I want to do now
is get a little bit of sort of salt
going in that cheese we're going to
caramelize that cheese and stick the
base of the bun on top of the cheese
just check my cheese out just for 10
seconds look at it
it's sort of it's going gooey it's
caramelizing and this is where the magic
starts this is where our Burgers start
to go next level take your bun very
carefully
and stick that onto the cheese
and just literally mop up
that cheese and look what's happening to
that base of the burger watch
Richard please because this this is
gonna go crazy I don't mind you using
this okay I'm totally stealing this I
don't mind you used it
and look a beautiful melted cheese